[Music]
on today's show we talked to a woman who
found out her husband was having
inappropriate text relationship with
somebody at work and she wants to know
what to do next
we talked to a woman whose dad is
getting out of jail and she wants to
know how she has a relationship with
them and we answer what is relational iq
stay tuned
[Music]
heyo
this is john with the dr john deloney
show
again i don't know why we're yelling
just sitting here on a podcast hanging
out sitting here on the tubes on the
youtubes
i pointed that way but i'm looking this
way man i'm kind of disoriented today i
hope you're not disoriented i hope you
are driving safe or vacuuming safe
or mowing or shoveling safe
whatever you're doing i hope you're
doing well so glad you're here
uh if you want to be on our show
call one eight 1-844-693-3291
leave a message tell us what's going on
in your life and we'll get back in touch
with you
and if you want to don't want to call in
you don't want your voice on the
internets forever
actually if you're on the show it will
be on forever but if you don't want your
voice on the internet if you just want
to send it via typing
via typing because i was born in the
1400s go to john delaney.com ask and
while you're there please everybody sign
up for the newsletter johndaloney.com
scroll down sign up for the newsletter
and the conversation cards are out
they're out into the wild and we are
changing families
we're changing you
and your relationships with your kids
and your spouse or your boyfriend
girlfriend with your in-laws
they are covet-free politics-free
we are re-learning how to be humans
we're gonna
give you some some ways you can ask some
questions of things you've always wanted
to know you're going to have to ask some
questions of things you did not want to
know
but
go to john dillon.com pick up the
conversation card you can get all three
packs man they're just like playing
cards with questions on they're awesome
and they are
man the feedback has been overwhelming
in a million years i would put these out
way sooner if i'd realized how much
people they were going to be helping
people in their homes and in their cars
and around their tables so go get go
check them out hey it actually would be
kind of fun if you made like a joke pack
that was just like fire starter and it
was like hey
um the grenades think about the vaccine
yeah and just like put in um what's your
least favorite world religion or like
just all these horrible things you james
that's happening i want to cut it'll be
the james and john and well my cut is
huge
by the way
my gut's not huge but there'll be the
james and john and kelly
grenade pack that would be so funny tell
us your thoughts on abortion what do you
think about dude this will be
incredible it will call the family ender
pack that'd be so awesome
how to get out of a conversation
oh man why did world trade center seven
collapse oh dude yes it the conspiracy
theory pack we'll do that with rachel
that'd be so fun
the ah pack with christy would be fun
the uh do you really know how that works
with kit that this would be a blast all
right cool go to johndooling.com get the
packs we are going to get to work right
away
on the
how to end your family pack or
how to throw a grenade lava grenade pack
i can't wait for that be awesome all
right let's go to ray in
san diego california hey what's going on
ray how are we doing
hi john thanks for having me on thanks
for calling thanks for calling thanks
for calling so what's up how can i help
um well i recently just found out that
my husband was
having like an
inappropriate texting relationship with
a co-worker
and i'm not really sure
how to
i guess repair the trust loss he seems
very
remorseful
you know says that he made a mistake but
i'm just not really sure how to trust
him again where to go from here yeah man
i'm sorry so
whenever somebody says it was an
inappropriate relationship i
in the past have jumped all over it and
then realized oh that was different than
i thought so paint me a picture of what
inappropriate was what was actually
going back and forth
so they were
talking
i guess about having a physical
relationship through text
she was offering to send him
inappropriate pictures
okay
it never got to that point are you sure
are you sure
yes i am sure i did look
she said that she was going to do it
over uh snapchat and never did i did
look
okay so and he cut it off at that point
okay so he got it got a little bit over
his skis and he got nervous and cut it
off
yes he said that if he had received
those pictures he would have known that
it would have crossed a different line
of inappropriate gotcha okay
so how long have you all been married
um it'll be seven years uh next year at
the beginning of the year so
about six and a half okay
um
so you asked the question how do you
rebuild trust
how do you repair this
and as i talk through here i want to
keep in mind two important things number
one
at the end of the day as much as this
how hard this is to hear
you can only
control you
okay
and
the repair of any the healing i don't
like to use the word repair because it's
not a machine but the healing of any
relationship takes two people
and what that means is you have to risk
you've got to go all in
and hope he goes all into
okay so keep that in mind as we talk
through this so the big question number
one is do you want to trust him again or
are you done
i do want to trust him again i don't
really want to
end our
family over it okay
so
tell me what you feel and here's what i
mean by that are you angry
are you scared that you almost lost him
are you frustrated because
once you heard about this you could see
yeah i've seen two years where we've
been disconnected i haven't done this
and and i haven't been open in this way
and i've i've i've been putting off
conversations and all of a sudden
or do you feel just raged out that
everything's been so great in your life
and then this guy went and did it like
what are you feeling
i'm a little confused because
we weren't
going through anything rough we weren't
having any hard times
we were both
you know what i thought was happy even
he said like there's nothing wrong
in our marriage he doesn't know why you
do that
so i'm confused and you know angry that
he would do that
but
it's all just kind of a big question
mark in my head right now yeah for sure
for sure
so um
somebody i i turn to often when i'm
trying to wrap my head around new ways
and old ways of looking at
infidelity whether it's just thoughts we
have and never even send a text message
or texting
that all of a sudden gets out of control
and all of a sudden we're meeting up
with somebody never meant or infidelity
like someone's just a serial cheater and
they've been having they've been you
know having physical intimate
relationships with other people for
years and years and years
sj peril
gives me she's a great um she's just a
great thought leader when it comes to
thinking about these things rethinking
about these things some things i
vehemently disagree with her on but that
does stretch my thinking and other
things she's just right on
so one of the things she talks about
that was important for me years ago when
i was thinking through this for the
first time wrestling with
how do people with quote unquote great
marriages end up in these other
situations
and she reports that in almost every
client she interacts with who's who's
had some sort of breach in the trust of
their marriage
every bit of research she's been a part
of
the word that comes up always is the
word alive
that the person who is involved in a
texting relationship the person who has
fantasies about somebody else's husband
or wife the person who
goes through it and has intimate
relationships outside of the bounds of
their committed relationship
they always come back and say it made me
feel alive
and here's where that's so important
is that
often we think or the narrative we've
been told about cheating is that there
must be something wrong with the
relationship there must be something
wrong with you
or your husband may not must not like
you or something you're doing
and that's why he went and did this
and what she's come back and said is
that's actually not right at all
he doesn't like something about him he
doesn't like who he's become in this
relationship
now it might be because he guys will say
all sorts of stupid things um
wives will say all sorts of stupid
things well it's because of this and the
towels and the way
it's i got sick of always coming home
frustrated
i got sick of always coming home to a
routine i got sick of coming home to
us introducing sex intimacy in the exact
same way in the exact same time
and this person made me feel alive i got
sick of coming home and nobody ever
recognizes my contribution to the house
they just take me for granted and and
and this person at work said dude you
are killing it on these reports
and suddenly my heart fluttered a little
bit nothing to do with romance nothing
to do with sex
i just felt for the first time in one
year two years 10 years 30 years
i felt alive i felt that guy look at me
in a way that my husband hasn't looked
at me in years
it's about alive and
luckily for the your relationship and i
say that intentionally
your husband got real close to the edge
and peered way over
and at the last second was like no i'm
not going to cross this line
and so
he did violate your he was keeping
secrets from you things got out of
control all that's true and real
and
okay none of these things are excuses by
the way this is just a context for i'm
trying to give you some ideas for this
confusion
i think this is way more about him than
it is about you
okay okay
now
he may not like the way he felt around
you because he doesn't think you're this
or you're not doing those things or what
that's secondary to
man something about this got his heart
racing again
that he felt in a way that he might not
have felt since y'all were dating or
since y'all were in year two or you're
whatever
so
what does trust look like for you what
do you when you say i just want to trust
him what does that mean
i guess not worrying about you know
who he's talking to now okay um
what he's doing when he's you know not
at work not at home
uh
he his job just kind of requires me to
have a lot of trust in him
so is he on the road on the road a lot
is he traveling people yeah okay he he
works away from home
um he travels for work so he's gone a
few days a week okay
and
if you are honest with yourself
can you trust him
i think i can
i mean like you know if you can or can't
do you trust you think can you trust him
or no
yeah okay
are you safe for him
meaning if you sat down and said
this [ __ ] on the radio
said that often when people find
themselves
in situations outside of their marriages
it's about them feeling alive
for the first time them feeling like
they're funny again they're feeling like
they are attractive again they're
feeling like they are capable again
tell me about how you felt when you were
texting back and forth
are you a safe place that he could tell
that be honest and truthful with you
yes because we're going back to things
that only you can control now okay
so if you sat down and said hey tell me
about what was just in your head could
you hear that
or it would just fill you up with rage
he would tell me he would tell you
awesome yeah
so
here's what
where you guys have a magic moment year
seven
that's a that's a notorious tough year
for folks years seven to ten that's when
we start to go oh this is who we are
and this is the way things are gonna be
do you have any little ones
yes we have two okay how old are they
uh one is five and the other is almost
two there you go so this is just gonna
be our life
um we're gonna always be wiping butts
and
um we're always gonna be having sex in
the dark as quick as possible so we can
go to sleep so we can get back up and
make a new bottle and make a new thing
and we're not going to go on dates
whatever that is
this year seven to ten is when it starts
to slowly
feel like this is the rest of our life
and this is a season when lots of these
things pop up either there's been some
infidelity for years it just finally
goes you know what i'm not doing this
anymore or this is when somebody starts
to go i feel dead on the inside for
whatever reason
and so
what i want you guys to look at this
opportunity as
a like the matrix a really close near
miss was there a violation for sure
um did your husband violate your trust a
thousand percent yes
but it didn't explode
there's not blood on the ceiling
oh my gosh it got close
and this is a moment y'all can choose
and you've heard me say this a hundred
times
you can excavate the whole thing
and say
how do we choose to lean into
feeling alive with each other again
how do we to use esther perel's language
how do we practice desire
i want to re-fall in love with you i
want to become a guy that makes your
heart flutter again
i want to become a
partner that makes you
think about me all day and when you're
traveling i'm going to make it hard for
you to do your job without wanting to
come home and be with me and that's not
just a sexual thing that is just a
friendship communication and a sexual
thing of course but
how do we rebuild that because we've
lost it we've been together for seven
years we're changing diapers we're tired
we're this and that i'm not
i'm not even showering anymore and
all my pants have stretchy things on
them man and this is both of you all
right
i get home from being out of town and i
just leave my
suitcase in a pile on the floor and my
clothes just stay there until i race
through to wash them again for my next
trip out like how do we reimagine this
thing
and i want you to lean in on two things
number one
what do you both need to feel alive
again
and be honest with each other be open
with each other
and the second thing is what are the
boundaries you need to re-establish
trust
meaning i need you when you get home i
want you to unlock your phone for the
next six months next year
like i want you just to put the phone
down or we're all going to have the same
code
if you have any i'm asking you to not
have any extra email accounts i want you
to delete them
i'm asking you to facetime me or if
somebody if you text another
um another person who's attracted you if
you text another woman
i want you to let me know that that
exchange happened
every single time
e and that's his responsibility to lean
into your boundaries
and so you're going to have to risk by
putting your boundaries out there and
saying i need you to meet these because
he might say i'm not doing that
and now you have another layer peeled
back of your relationship
i hear in your voice you don't think
that's the case you think he'll do
whatever you say is that right
yeah so it seems
really remorseful he said he would do
whatever it took to fix this awesome so
you be honest about your boundaries and
you may need to sit down and talk to
somebody you may need to go out with a
friend and just vent and you all write
down on a piece of paper be so clear
here's the boundaries here's what's
going to make me feel safe
and
know that he's practicing trust you're
practicing trust
and when you get a text from him in four
months and it's like hey
my boss she texted me and let me know
that i need to be at work tomorrow at
eight and you go i don't care that's
when you'll know
okay or when he
texts you and says hey we're all going
to lunch
and
um
there's going to be three of my female
colleagues and just me are you okay with
that and you're like why would i yes i
don't care that's when you'll know and
if it's a year from now two years from
now and you say not a good idea i don't
feel right about that you'll let him
know and he'll go great cool no problem
is that
you see what i'm leaning into
it's creating a safe place y'all can
talk about being alive and it's creating
a safe place where you can your
boundaries can be heard and he can lean
into him and just know it's going to be
frustrating because this is all new and
he's going to forget to text once and
he's going to catch himself and send it
understand that he's practicing and
trying
and you're practicing and trying to i
think this
this might be one of those moments that
launches your relationship into a new
stratosphere
and you can not just say things are
going great i want you to be able to
define great
what is this thing that we are creating
who are we gonna be why are we doing
this
and how can we both work together to let
the other one feel alive
does that sound exciting
yes it does and that's
really good ideas of what to do that
kind of answers my question there
awesome just not a
bridge i've gone over before yeah hey
we're in it now you're in and out and
you're committed and he sounds like he's
committed
this is perfect this is perfect
ghost excavate the whole thing and y'all
go out somewhere dream about what this
can look like and again when y'all go
out this isn't a punishment session for
him this isn't you gonna take him out
and be like and i did at this sounds
like y'all have had that conversation
this is you saying
something about this made you feel alive
and i want you to feel alive with me
and i want to feel alive again with you
and we've got these two kids that we
love dearly
and they have taken much of our life
with them and so it's our job to
recreate desire to recreate intimacy to
recreate laughter and sexuality and
commitment and
aliveness
and i don't even think aliveness is a
word but y'all can create it in your
house who cares
so great
i want to know how this conversation
goes so have this conversation build
something cool draw the blueprints and
begin building and then write me back
and let me know how things are going ray
thank you so much for your vulnerability
talk to you soon we'll be right back on
the dr john dalona show
[Music]
hey good folks and friends and listeners
to the dr john deloney show
the world is bonkers right we all know
this and one of the most common
questions i get is how do i find a
counselor in the chaos i've reached out
and there's a six month waiting list or
i can't afford it or they only take
insurance or i can't get off work and
time to go see somebody it's way across
town what do i do because i want help
with my anxiety my depression my
relationships are hanging on by a thread
i want to be a better mom i gotta
process this trauma that happened to me
when i was a kid
where do i find a counselor
so i partnered with better help because
betterhelp is customized online therapy
that offers video phone even live chat
sessions so you don't even have to look
at your therapist when you're talking to
them if you don't want to i've taken
away all your excuses and it's more
affordable than in-person therapy and
these are real
licensed therapists if you reach out to
them you will be talking to somebody
within 48 hours dr john daloni show
listeners get 10 off their first month
at betterhelp.com
please reach out if you need help that's
betterhelp.com
deloney
all right we are back crackerjack let's
go to taryn in fresno it's an all
california show today what's up taryn
hi doctor nidalani thank you so much for
taking my call thank you for calling and
i don't know why i'm so loud today i
feel loud sorry i would if you just me
wake up it's okay but if you and me like
met at a coffee shop i wouldn't be like
hello karen i wouldn't do that i don't
know why i'm yelling so dumb
so let me i'm gonna i'm gonna back that
thing up okay
um
we'll slap it up flip it reverse it okay
so hey good morning taran what's up how
are we doing
i'm good how are you i feel so much
better to talk to you like a human not
like i'm like yeah radio i am good so
what's going on how could it help
yeah so um
so my dad has been in prison my entire
life
well let's just get right into it it's a
great way to start a conversation right
hey so what happened why has he been in
jail your whole life
um so he was um
he was sentenced when i was about three
months old um
and he is a sex offender okay um
so yeah that happened when i was just a
few months old he's been gone ever since
were you the victim
i was not no okay what was the what was
the offense
um so
without getting like into too much
detail or getting too graphic um
he was he had a lot of uh
abuse when he was growing up
from you know other people like in the
church and his family
and that kind of progressed to
him doing the same kind of abuse when he
was an adult okay uh so he was like
yeah okay all right
um okay so he's been in jail your whole
life how and how many years is that 20
years 30 years uh 25 25 okay
yeah
so he is getting released uh at the end
of next month
can i just guess does he want to yeah
does he want to kick it all back up and
make up for lost time and get his
daughter back
uh
kind of okay so i
he
probably the past like a year or two i
mean we will
we'll write letters back and forth here
and there to stay in contact
we have kind of tried to heal the
relationship a little bit
but
riding back and forth and you know
with visitation and everything and you
then covet hit no visitation was allowed
to happen that wall was always there so
it was kind of easy and it was okay but
now that he's getting out and it's all
in person
it's like
i don't even know where to start so i
guess my my main question for you is
how do i
how do i
maintain this relationship in a healthy
way with
healthy boundaries i guess is my
question
um okay so i'm gonna lean into a hard
thing
okay and the hard thing is this
i'm gonna talk to somebody else about
their dad
and i'm gonna be really honest and
that can sometimes cross my own personal
boundaries which is to not
say ugly things about other people's
parents
is that cool
it's it's okay it really is okay
um so let's start it this way
take all of the
daughters supposed to fill in the blank
with their dad supposed to love their
dad and respect their dad take the fact
away that he's your dad
let's just talk about this guy let's
call him let's call him dan let's talk
about dan
what do you think of dan
[Music]
be honest
um i
probably not the best things but i mean
like hey that's what like that's what i
want to hear you say out loud like what
do you think about dan
because here's my guess my guess is you
have wrapped up your feelings
and what you really think
and your gut
and your rage and your anger and your
heart brokenness
under this
daughter duty to dad
i may be way out of line there but
that's my guess
and you have tried to make it work
because i'm supposed to forgive i'm
supposed to burn my dad
what do you really think about dan
honestly i was really
disgusted with him i i just didn't
understand how someone could do that
even
even with all the abuse he had as a
child i mean i understand
how it led up not saying that i agree
with it but
everyone's still got a choice
everyone's still got a choice could care
less what happened yeah yes exactly yeah
and i was
i was very angry i was very disgusted
for a long time we we didn't talk for a
number of years actually just because of
the whole situation
once i was old enough and i
found out everything that happened once
you know that my mom and him actually
were able to tell me what happened
and how old were you when that happened
um
it's probably about 15 or so so did they
was there a big cloud did they lie to
you for the first 15 years of your life
about where dad was
um
so my mom was my mom did live for a
number of years staying where he was um
she
would just kind of make up random things
i don't remember all of them but it of
course it was avoiding the fact that he
was in prison
um he was actually telling my mom and i
that he was in a sense this entire time
and then when i was about 14 or 15 or so
he actually came to my mom and me like
wrote us a letter and told us that he
was actually guilty of all those things
so
he
told my mom and i the truth at the same
time and then my mom kind of gave me a
more detailed explanation so
it kind of hit everybody
suddenly yeah and it was it was
surprising and that was the time that i
didn't really talk to him for a while
um probably till i was about 18 or 19 or
so he kind of
wrote me out of the blue and he wanted
to apologize for everything that
he did and that he's been going through
you know treatments and therapy and
um
kind of
taking his mental illness into
consideration and trying to find
treatment for that so just basically
that he's changed and that he's trying
to forgive himself and move forward and
all that and
ever since then it's just kind of been
on and off and rocky and it's to this
day it's still hard to talk to him yeah
and i just don't know what to say
sometimes i don't know how to have a
conversation with this guy sometimes and
it's hard so that's just kind of where
i've been at yeah man well thank you for
walking us through that so
i don't want to miss the scope of this
trauma and you've lived this but i want
to put words to it
your dad left you
and if he had left you and your mom for
another woman when you were three months
old that would have been trauma
because you would have spent your
childhood years wondering what was so
great about that other woman
that dad left me
like i'm his baby girl and he left me
and then there was the trauma of finding
out that your mom lied to you for years
whether she thought she had to or not
whatever that's not the point the point
is that it happened
i'm not about blame and all that it
happened
yeah and so then there's a fracture in a
relationship between you and your mom
and my guess is y'all will ride or die
at that moment because you're all she's
all you had
and then to find out
i
i don't
i don't nothing i i know is true
because mom the one person i had didn't
tell me the truth about my whole life
and then to find out
oh there's daddy's back
oh by the way
he did the most evil egregious thing a
person can do which is take the
innocence away from a child
and by the way daughter
if you
will have me back
i'd sure love to come back
and so then this whole thing wraps up in
a pretty bow and a package and handed to
you which is
you get to heal yourself from all this
trauma and you get to heal all these
things and it all rests on you which is
another trauma
it's kind of like my friends i've had
several friends who get cancer and they
will tell me
almost worse than the cancer diagnosis
is that they are now responsible for
making every person in their life feel
better
and that's what just happened to you
now it's your job
what are you going to say to dad are you
going to have dad over are you going to
let me back in your life and suddenly
you the child are responsible for
healing these adult relationships
yeah and so i need
like i know you know this i'm not
telling you that you don't know you're
clearly brilliant and you are clearly
been through tough as nails you've been
there a lot
but the trauma is that you've
experienced that your body has had to
navigate is deeper than just your dad
committed an atrocity
it's that since you were three months
old you have been
uh a balloon on a string just floating
up in space
does that does that ring true with your
body does that ring true
i haven't really ever put words into it
or put it into words but yeah it does
my guess is you are
really good at your job
and you don't take crap from anybody or
you take crap from everybody and you say
i'll take care of it you're either a war
finder or a peacekeeper which one are
you
i'm a peacekeeper there you go
i will make sure that everything goes
and when a peacekeeper is a peacekeeper
for a long time the one person that
doesn't have peace in their soul is them
and i just want to tell you i
i could probably
get choked up here pretty quick i felt
like myself i'm sorry this happened to
you
because you're kind of awesome
not kind of you're all the way awesome
and you deserved a better shot out of
the cannon than you got
and you deserve to be anchored into
people who say
i freaking love taryn
she's incredible
and if i'm the first person to ever tell
you that shame on everybody around you
but i'm glad i get to be the person to
tell you that
are you married
i am yeah
somebody good
yeah very good
a good anchor
oh yeah
do you ever get to put the peacekeeper
down and just go full tearing
just go full
either it's full rage or full dance or
full we're turning the strobes on and
we're turning on the house music and
we're gonna rock this thing on or full i
can be wildly intimate with this person
like are you able to let peacekeeper go
um
probably the only person i can do that
with is with my husband okay
he's he's seen me try so hard to make
people happy
and i just exhaust myself or i get sick
or whatever ends up happening and he
just kind of
he kind of tells me when to just be
myself and relax or he'll sometimes
he'll come in and he'll pick up the
pieces so i don't have to
so here's your work
your work is not
fixing your family
that was done to you that's not your job
your job is to heal taren
and
man what a stud that you married that
loves you enough to walk alongside you
my dream and hope for you taryn
is that in short order
you don't need somebody else
to tell you when you've done enough
you'll be able to trust your body for
the first time
you'll be able to trust taryn for the
first time
you'll be able to stand tall and say you
know what i want today
craziness
you know what i want today i want to
we're knocking off work and we're going
to dance until we can't move you know
what i want to do i'm going hiking until
my legs don't work anymore i want
and that's the work
because i think you've been nice long
enough
and i think you've squashed taran for a
long long long time
and none of this is why you call right
yes and no
so
here's the deal about your dad
any sort of relationship you do or don't
have is on your terms
your dad cashed in his ticket
when he chose to steal
the most precious thing from a person
which is their innocence
from one two twenty fifty however many
kids there were
he made a choice to say i am no longer
going to have influence or um
presence
in the life of my one
sacred daughter
i'm choosing that
and i know he's got demons and i know
he's been hurt and evil and hurt people
hurt people all that but he made a
choice i'm choosing
this
over
influence and presence in my daughter's
life
and that's a choice he made and he's got
to live with that and you've got to live
with that your mom's got to live with
that the whole ecosystem has to live
with that
and you have to let the fantasy go and
this is a hard thing for peacekeepers
because peacekeepers live in a fantasy
world that if they just do the right
things in the right order that everyone
else's world will be okay
and that's not real
so you have to let the fantasy go
that he's gonna come out you're gonna
have this big hugging moment and he's
gonna slowly start coming around and one
day he'll be able to hang out with your
kids and it will be lovely and we got
dad back
that's not real and that's not gonna
happen
no
you've got to build something totally
new and you've got to start over with
all that knowledge in mind
and if you say
you know what after doing some work on
taryn i don't want to be in a
relationship with this guy don't
no obligation
if you say for the first two years
you're out of jail you can write one
letter to my house a month i will burn
every other letter that comes and i will
not see you in person
for two years you can write me a letter
and then maybe i'll meet with your
parole officer and see if you are living
up to the recidivism rate for
um
this type of sex offender is
the odds of him recommitting are very
high
right and so
i get to do whatever i want to do
because i'm freaking tearing
right
yeah and so hear me say
i want you to be completely and totally
at peace
with whatever you want to do
and however you want to build it
and the moment somebody sends you a mean
text and says well you know what you
should done blocked next
the moment your mom says well i was
hoping we could all get blocked tech
next
because for the first time taryn's not
going to be keeping everybody else's
peace taryn's going to keep peace inside
of taryn
which is going to give her husband peace
it's going to give her kids peace it's
going to give her a workplace and her
environment peace
and then maybe
i'll reach out to that guy
or hey tell me i'm all crazy taryn tell
me i'm bananas and say no i really
really want a relationship with him
you can do that too but it's on your
terms hear what i'm saying
yeah i do so here's what i want to have
happen i want you and husband to go out
i want you to let him talk
i want you to let him speak into he
loves you he's walked alongside you he's
seen you hurt he's seen you cry he's try
he's seen you try to make everybody
else's world okay
both professionally personally everybody
i want to get his thoughts on
letting dad back in your life
and then
i want you to let it go
for the first time
whether you have to write it down
whether you just get a laptop and start
typing you have permission to type
because i have a feeling that a lot will
come out and
your hand may not be able to catch up on
the yellow pad but right right right
right right right taren
what do you really feel where do you
want to go where do you want to live
what do you want to do what world you
want to create you've been creating
everybody's world for a long long time
taryn
who do you want to be what do you want
to be
start there and then decide i want to
let this disgusting person back in my
life
i believe in redemption
but sometimes redemption has a slow long
arc
[Music]
and to anyone out there who hurts kids
god help you
don't stop
go get help quit turn yourself in
whatever but stop
because you don't just hurt the kids you
hurt their entire family systems you're
at the entire kids
ecosystem you hurt your kids your spouse
their kids their grandkids
that type of evil roils through it just
burns through generations
we'll be right back on the doctor john
dewine show
the world has become more and more
chaotic and uncertain and loud and it
seems that everyone has anxiety i've
been there and so have you
it's why i wrote this small direct and
personal book called redefining anxiety
in this book i discuss what anxiety is
what it's not and how you can get back
on the road of being whole and well
listen
you are not broken and i'm living proof
that you can get your life back i wrote
this book so everyone could read it not
just science nerds like me and my
friends and i priced it at 10 bucks so
that everyone can afford it this little
book landed on the bestseller list and
is now being purchased by the case and
given away in counseling offices
universities churches and homes across
the country i don't care if you're a
teenager or an executive or a 75 year
old grandmother this book is for
everyone so go to johndeloney.com and
get your copy of redefining anxiety
today
all right we're back
dude if this podcasting doesn't work out
i'm for sure going to be a professional
singer because i'm awesome
um so
i'm
on a couple of these shows here um
instead of taking a third call i want to
get some of these emails folks because i
say stuff all the time and then folks
write in like you say this all the time
what do you mean by this or by that you
always talk about
kids have a role and talk about
relational iq what are you talking about
i think it's fair just to set context
um but kind of what i'm talking about so
um this question comes from katie
hello catherine
i'm assuming you're a catherine if
you're just a regular katie shake it off
oh my gosh i love taylor swift too all
right katie asks what is relational iq
you say it all the time but i have no
idea what it means
[Laughter]
i asked that like in a in a
snarky voice like the way i'm reading
this is like katie's like you're kind of
an idiot why do you always say this i
don't know what you're talking about but
it could be that katie's like really
brilliant and it's like never heard of
this it's not in a textbook what do you
mean
here's what i mean katie
relational iq is
simply
who are you
in relationship to those around you
who's your community your personal your
neighborhood your nation your spiritual
community
where can you be vulnerable where do you
have congruence and authenticity what i
mean by that is where can you be fully
you
who gets the real you
is that just one friend in one place
is that just your
wife just your husband
or can you pretty much be the same
person at work as you are at home as you
are with your friends as you are at the
grocery store that's congruence can i
just be myself in all these places and
if i can't why not
what have you contributed to this
community what do you contribute to this
community on an ongoing basis and what
do you take from this community
are you a leech
are you the person that everyone is
always pouring into and you just got
holes in the bottom of your bucket and
everything's always running through you
i need more i need more or
like the last caller are you the person
that makes sure everybody else's bucket
is full even if it means dumping yours
out so that they've got something
so when i talk about relational iq i'm
talking about
how do you show up
how do you come across to those people
in your life whether you work with them
you
drive with them you sit by them at the
grocery store you mow your lawn next to
theirs how do you set boundaries how do
you honor other people's boundaries how
do you love yourself your immediate
circle and how do you show up for
strangers in the world
and relational iq asks
how do other people experience me and
how do i experience other people
here's a good example
i am
exhausted
last night i was up to 1 am finishing up
book edits i thought the book addicts
were going to take two hours they took
eight
on a one chapter just grinding it out on
one particular chapter
shocking i talked too much and so i got
it back and needed to cut like 3000
words
so i'm cutting and cutting and cutting
and then trying to reorient and because
one chapter one section leads to another
section i gotta adjust that section and
completely cut this one out and then
it's like now i gotta put them back in
hours and hours and hours
my relational iq asks
when my kids walk in am i putting just
this thing down and being a present with
my kids
i happen to be editing right in the
middle of the living room which made me
the epicenter of all these other people
all these other relationships so i'm
this big pulsing
just beacon of frustration and beacon of
i'm locked in and zoned into something
and my kids are bouncing off my
electric force field
saying oh dad's radioactive hey dad you
want to play hey dad um look at this
maybe if i cry dad will will look at me
maybe if i break something dad will look
at me and my wife is tiptoeing around
the house because she's like i don't
know if that is a bug zapper i don't
know if that pulse of energy is anger
or rage or just completely focused she's
a writer too so she understands me when
you get locked in you get locked in
and
or is that a cry for help it's probably
a little bit of all that stuff
i didn't have good relational iq last
night
relational iq would have been i don't
want to be the epicenter of i don't want
my energy to screw up everybody's night
and i know i'm going to have a night
where i got to grind something out for a
while
so i should have gone in the basement i
should have stayed at work
i should have said hey i love you guys i
miss you guys i'm going to send flowers
or i'll be home later tonight you'll
have the best night ever go out to
dinner and have a great time
um i got a project i got to finish but
instead i tried to do it all that was
bad relational iq because then my son
ends up just going in his room shutting
the door going to bed early like
i'd rather not engage with this my
daughter
if she feels tension she's all in
and then she ends up a
crying mess and then i try to oversolve
the cry and then my wife's like hey i've
got this you get back to do it which
then i'm like oh cause i can't p
bad relation like you
good relation iq is
how am i feeling today how's the world
gonna experience me how do i change my
attitude how do i know hey i'm running
kind of hot so if somebody runs in and
goes hey i need you to do this that i'm
not going to lash out at them and bite
their head if i'm going to say
[Applause]
yeah let me get right on that or hey can
you run that by so-and-so because i
don't have the bandwidth take care of it
today relation iq is knowing how i'm
going to interact with other people and
understanding that other people may be
running hot
so when i say hey i needed this a week
ago and it's late and they snap at me
going that's probably not about me
probably not about me i got a lot going
on um i'm gonna circle back um i'm gonna
ask you to be respectful when we talk
but i'm gonna circle back relation like
you how do i experience the world and
how's the world experience me in all
these areas personal neighborhood nation
spiritual i know some days 99 of them i
don't need to go checking on the news
a it's nonsense it's bullcrap it's not
real they're trying to get me riled up
and
it's gonna make me respond to other
people negatively not good ways so i'm
just going to roll off
what conversations am i avoiding which
conversations am i having
relational iq is how you show up for
those you care about which should be
everyone
how do you respond to conflict how do
you support those you love
that when i say relational iq is what
i'm talking about
if you want to have a good relation like
you it all starts with you going back to
yourself and saying
can i identify my body can i be honest
and understand when i'm bringing
my
shenanigans my pain my trauma my lack of
sleep my poor nutrition my
feeling good my excitement to a
situation
and can i respond in a way that is
dignified and kind
and yet
holds my boundaries to other people
what are my boundaries what does
kindness look like for me what does
respect look like for me that's
relational iq
hope that helps katie thanks for writing
in
diane i say these things all the time
and i don't realize that people are like
uh don't know what you're talking about
all right so as wrap up today's show
this is gonna be the most controversial
thing i've ever said on the internets
without a doubt
the song of the day
is by somebody universally revered as
the greatest songwriter of all time
he does have some extraordinary songs
but
this isn't the best version of this song
song is written by bob dylan
which by the way
it's one of only two live shows i've
ever walked out of the show is not great
it's heart
it his heart
but i do recognize he's bob dylan and
everyone should bow and reverence and
all that stuff wear purple robes and
whatever
the song is don't think twice
and the lyrics are incredible
but i heard it
on mike ness's record cheating at
solitaire his country record he's the
singer of social distortion he had a
country record called cheating a
solitaire which is an incredible record
and i remember thinking that is how that
song should have sounded so i just broke
all the music rules on the internet you
don't you think bob dylan is it yes bob
dylan's great but mike nessa's version
of this song is better the song is don't
think twice and it goes like this
well there ain't oh by the way mike ness
plays offender on this song
i play uh les paul because of mike ness
and he showed up on the tele with a
telecaster on this song
kind of broke my heart a little bit both
and john
oh ladies wait a weapon way to use me
against me
that was like yoda
chopping off luke's hand with his own
lightsaber
well there ain't no use to sit and
wonder why if you don't know by now and
it ain't no use to sit and wonder why
doesn't matter anyhow when the rooster
crows at the break of dawn look out your
window i'll be gone
you're the reason i'm traveling on but
don't think twice it's all right
it's so great it ain't no use turn on
your light the light i never knew and it
ain't no use and turning on your light
i'm on the dark side of the road i wish
there was something you could do or say
make me want to change my mind and stay
we never did much talking anyway
but don't think twice
it's all right
bob dylan
it's one of the greatest diss songs of
all time just like this show
see you soon on the dr john dolan show
[Music]